dt was with the cast of girls as they
celebrated their final season in New
York City Malia Obama was even there and
eyewitness spotted her at the after
party the former first daughter in
turned on the show you promised that
Holly's picked you think I'm gonna stop
being your friend now after putting up
with all this boat to the end those
would be on the debris on that's the
last was last night and now I get it now
I'm can I thought like when I wrapped
that was gonna the heaviest moment no it
just keeps going it was emotional
getting ready tonight to knowing the
last time keeping stuff from set my
favorite I kept Hannah's headboard I
kept all of Hannah's winter coats and
all of Hannah's jewelry I was like the
person who was like I'm taking my whole
apartment and had to be stopped now the
question is will we get a movie next is
that always the question when a series
ends is every series making a movie I
think Leda said it you know you have to
wait and pick up on where these girls
are and maybe five years or four years
or something like that I think that
makes sense and I think that that's what
will if we ever do do it make a movie
interesting when they're 60 you know the
little movie when they're 16 that's the
plan
you